thank you thank you and welcome
and when I was five items I scientists
in Switzerland British scientists put
online the World Wide Web I don't think
it made the headlines anymore but 25th
birthday this one and it's pretty
amazing what happened in last 25 years
with it right we can do things like live
in Vancouver and work for a company in
Chicago we can you know meet in Iceland
at a conference with people from all
over the world and most important of all
we can look at cute cat videos all times
of the day so that was a pretty big
change and that's kind of symbol of how
I feel about machine learning I'd like
to use the much cooler sounding
intelligence or AI and yeah it's kind of
like a like the Internet it's a general
purpose technology we had two talks
already that talked about using AI to
generate art Google is using it to drive
cars and I'm going to talk about using
it to do natural language processing the
cool thing about the web browser is that
Google and Mozilla actually offering us
an API maybe you've seen yesterday to do
speech speech recognition but to make
sense of that language is a little
harder and just like parsing HTML not
possible with regular expressions so I
have this you probably can't see this
but there's
pile of wires over there it wasn't my
gray decide you to bring my own audio
setup there's some good helps to get it
all working hopefully and the reason I
said I brought I talked to it by
pressing this button it's a little it's
called a flick you can get them before
pax 2 it's actually pretty cool you hook
it up to your Android device or other
Bluetooth enabled device we were about
that yesterday and yeah it's literally
just a button but you can program it to
do stuff and I programmed it to get my
friend to listen so let's see if that
works
hey can you hear us yeah so this already
starting out that that's okay hey can
you hear you might see that I don't know
what you're talking about screen a
little more often I'm gonna explain it a
little more as well cool do you want to
tell us your name
actually came from me watching too many
movies about hey I might know Samantha
from the movie her and Samaritan from
personal interest the you is actually
inspired by it but besides that this
thing has nothing to do with an AI
companion that us run the world so maybe
you can tell us what you do know do you
want to tell us what you do maybe you
can quickly go over what this is
actually this screen is the texts that
it got let's try one more time can you
tell us what you do so it's an open
source intelligent in quotation marks
couse it is obviously still pretty dumb
a system that you can train and extend
yourself um you might know or use Siri
or Alexa or M which is still in beta
there's many many things like that come
up in the last little while and they're
all kind of still like black boxes and
this thing you can teach your own
language and also extent with plugins
written in html5 and JavaScript it's
pretty cool the whole thing actually is
written in JavaScript and I'm gonna go
into the tech in a little bit okay when
you don't know what else to say you just
talk about weather hey what's the
weather like dramatic pause so this is
actually an example for a plugin it's
using plain gyah create simple weather
now you can also ask for a city please
don't need a city because yahoo doesn't
allow to ask for anything else anymore
and for I think the next little bit I
might need a volunteer but let me first
show you what you're getting into
I brought another mic that you can use
and we'll try is it stubborn for you
this is the only evil robot joke in this
talk I'm gonna not do any other ones
cool what's the weather like cool and
maybe the last thing is you can actually
look up general things like cool so we
can do three things if I have a
volunteer that wants to try it out we
can go through the process and see what
happens this is you know this is like so
let's let's see if it works so maybe
start with you
see this thing makes me way better jokes
than me all right let's figure out the
weather so the cool thing about this is
that you get say hey this is not right
I'm gonna teach you a new thing all
right now the most the most interesting
part is
so what is the answer to the universe
everything
oh let's try what is the answer to life
the universe and everything so as you
see
Thank You max all right this actually
turned out way more entertaining than I
thought it would be
now before we look on under the hood on
what's happening yes let's talk for a
couple minutes about the technology so
it's a natural language processing
libraries per node it has like some
basic things like
tokenization of a sentence it also has
basic classification and that was cool
but the classification runs on
statistical analysis and I thought it
would be an interesting exercise because
I've been watching too many movies
yeah to hook it up to a neural network
yesterday
so you can use that to put sentences in
to train it with certain sentences and
then get label them and get
probabilities back that I put something
else so typical um yeah neural network
machine learning thing now I know this
isn't feathers is another thing I mean
and I know this talk is not about
feathers but I can't just and I think it
also covers something that's that's
still kind of important and not done
that often which is how do we make
machine learning data available publicly
right I mean Siri and light box
citizen living room but how do you how
do you make it publicly available and
not just within SDK but actually has an
API so what feathers does it's kind of
like a small library on top of Express
that lets you create and consume rests
and real-time API and that's it so you
can pick whichever that database you
want you can pick whichever front-end
technology one it's just this connector
in between and what this basically does
in this case is gives us a database
connection just to store stuff it's
using any DB because the whole thing
will it's running in a browser right now
but it also can run an electron so that
means that we don't want people to
install MongoDB and stuff like that it's
just a file based database and and then
it also provides the connection because
it also works in the Kline between the
front-end app and the backend and then
we have election react steel which is a
module loaded
throwing stuff dynamically without
having to build it I needed that for the
plug-in system which will hopefully have
some time to look into cool um so
there's two three hmm hey that's my man
someone always changed so there's a
couple things to it the first one and I
don't even think I have to blow that up
because this queen is huge maybe a
little bit
the first one is actions an action is
basically something that you want it to
do if you haven't met a sentence try and
pull out something that's similar so in
our case of the two tag goes from
position 4 to 4 which is your
so if somebody says can you hi there my
name is it'll usually try and pull out
the information around that sense this
is actually a pretty dumb algorithm but
it works so well because the
classification of the neural network is
so accurate that you don't have to worry
about the sentences being so different
so this is how it gets where what's the
weather in Vancouver and things like
that
then we have something here reply with a
couple of things and this is the search
of course this has been done by people
way smarter than me already and there's
an API for it and a really cool one
actually that I hope I have some time to
show a little bit so this is actions
there's only 11 of them and then the
next part of the thing we have is
trainings so you know people always
think that millions and millions
well it's somewhat accurate
so this basically maps text to an action
every time we make a new classification
it'll save you when it's not sure it'll
save and Retraining put that one so that
every time master and the action is
basically just the action
oh sorry it's all good I'm gonna go back
here then I thought this one this one
did work sorry about that
okay so this sounds better so now we
have actions and trainings the last part
of the API actually is the interesting
one which is the classification and
classification is basically you can just
post to this classify endpoint with your
actual text so if you say can you tell
us the weather in Berlin and they send
this it'll come back with something like
this the texts the tokens tokens are
just each individual word stems are
interesting this is basically the base
form of the word so that if you have
singular plural it doesn't matter
or if you have other languages that add
a lot of things at the end of words you
want to know what the actual word is
about so that's pretty useful and by the
way this should ideally also work with
other languages I tried it briefly with
German I unfortunately didn't have
enough time but because it's all based
on word stems and neural networks you
can train it in your own language if it
is possible too
if no natural has a stammer for it so it
can build the bit create the base forms
over work cool this is the action that
it created basically it creates a new
action for us and this is the confidence
so it's actually pretty confident
already because we've done it many times
there's 96 percent confident that this
is what I want and this is the original
action that it got trained with now if
you look back into the browser you'll
see that
it's yeah there we go
you'll see that it updated and browsers
already now it still has to bend at
humans land on the moon in it's pretty
warm in Berlin alright so what happens
in the background is let's make this a
little bigger too because this is where
the action machine learning part happens
you'll see here it gives us a list of
labels to values and those are the
confidences of what action you want to
perform so we'll see here there's a
whole bunch of them that are like less
than one lesson way less than 10% but
this one is 92 percent and this is
exactly the one that we wanted it to do
so that was really cool to see under the
hood and how it gets better the more you
train it alright give me back my browser
let's briefly look at how to build a
plugin because I found it really
important to make it almost as easy as
even though jQuery is not used as much
anymore it's still the creating a plugin
for it was the easiest thing you could
ever do and I really like that so a
plugin basically has a client and a
server file and on the server in our
case for this one I'm gonna actually
show you first what this plug-in is
about this is the looking up information
on the internet and it's using Wolfram
Alpha which is by the people that also
made Mathematica and it's a knowledge
engine so instead of things like google
it that looks up relevant links for you
it actually tries to get the meaning
from what you ask it so when did people
land
the moon it'll give us way more oops way
more information then what we got back
in the answer but you'll basically get
the same the same things so this is
pretty cool because I didn't have to do
it you just used the API and then
display it on the client so what we did
here was use the node API plug-in create
a new client with the app ID this is
only a test API key if you want to use
it and then it will create a new feather
service it's kind of like a a middleware
except for that it has a crud object
that you pass and in this create so if
you post or call create will create a
query with grab the query from the data
and then just get the result from the
client and return it back so this is
just an API endpoint just like the
classified service that we posted to and
on the client we have the same feathers
app but two additional things one is
learn so when you saw the I don't know
what you're talking about screen you can
basically add things to the drop-down
and say okay now tell me the weather now
do this and now do that you can create
your own forms and submit your own data
in here and then we have the actual
actions so when the action is certain
enough so when so more than 50% sure
it'll just perform the action and what
we do here is pretty much get the text
make a query here to our service that we
created on the server so the cool thing
about this is that it's fine agnostic
now so we could also put it on our
mobile phones or mobile apps or electron
which is what it's going to run in as
the distributable and then we have the
results and just print the main or
primary primary result oh and then so
that's pretty much it and then and then
this is a plug
tear down function so you just clear it
out so you can use whatever technology
you want you get all the information
that it got trained with and then you
can perform whichever actions you you
would like so that was pretty fun and
and this once I had the whole system in
place was actually really quick to do
and I spent like a whole afternoon
asking it random questions all right so
that this whole project started as I
should have to remember to stay here
this whole project started as a demo for
the Calgary meetup that I hauled from
the front moved to Vancouver and we
wanted to just show hey here's some
things that you can do with feathers and
let's let's try and use some AI so we
build a collaborative gesture teaching
app which was really cool
it was a clunky but it worked and the
next step was to go into the nest
language processing and I couldn't find
anything related to it except for the no
natural library for for JavaScript and
there's only two personal assistant
projects similar there is serious which
is a research project that tries to do
much more like make sense of photos and
learn from everything not just language
stuff and Jasper I think which is a
Python app that's built to run on your
Raspberry Pi or device like that and
this one on the other hand I do really
like to have as a desktop app and a web
app and it worked really well as a demo
and and then I just continue working on
it to continue working on it and three
weeks ago I was hacking away and I was
teaching in new things and it recognized
them and when it didn't then I showed it
new things and all of a sudden went and
once it learned a little more it was
really weird cuz
it got less and less sure of things that
had learned before so if I said thank
you it would be like I'm only 20 percent
sure you want me to say you're welcome
and that was really weird because you
know as a programmer we used to for
programming it in once and it'll like
just work forever so I try to figure out
what the problem is and I think sorry
it's really helpful sometimes to have a
non programmer sounding board because
then you have to explain it in different
terms and when I did that I said so I
built this thing and it works
but it's super confused with the old
stuff the new stuff it knows really well
but the old stuff it doesn't and we
talked about it was like Dave you
accidentally build Marvin the Paranoid
Android and and and that was really
interesting because the programmer right
you always like okay a program at him
once and it'll work and I get mad if it
doesn't work even with Siri you're like
cursing Apple because they didn't get
what you wanted to do and that was the
case here too the problem was no
positive reinforcement it was I was only
telling it when he was wrong what else
it was supposed to do so that was really
interesting for me to learn that you
have to treat it less like programming
and more like teaching a person or
teaching someone which was really cool
for me to see because I think in the
near future we might be you know
teaching our software as much as we
program them and looking at where those
data are stored how they're shared and
where they're coming from is gonna be
come more and more important and just
like we meet better operating systems
with at least making parts of it
open-source I think there should be a
way for training data for machine
learning to be shareable as well there
is not even a shareable format neural
networks work various have a fairly
similar architecture in most programming
languages and there isn't a standardized
format yet to to to exchange it so if I
train it
Google's tensorflow I can't drop it into
brain js2 use it in the browser and I
think that's gonna be going to be pretty
important in the future and I find it
pretty exciting because it's well it's
way more unpredictable but that's how
our work is every day anyway
and working with the computer the same
way we work with other people I find
pretty exciting and one thing I want to
work on a little more is turn this into
a fancy generator that just scaffolds
you app by asking you a couple questions
it's a pretty basic step but it will
make things a lot easier because you can
actually interact more instead of going
through a command line and yeah if you
interest in this as well come chapter me
this is it for me and thanks everybody
for being here